On its opening weekend, the Stephen King adaptation
It broke multiple box-office records when
it pulled in $123 million — the biggest-ever
September opening for a film, horror or otherwise.
We can't ignore the impressive performances
from the young cast, and, of course, the film's
terrifying demon clown.
Let's take a closer look at this group of
fictional misfits, and the talented young
actors who brought their characters to life
on the big screen.
Jaeden Lieberher
Before landing a starring role in It as Bill
Denbrough, actor Jaeden Lieberher started
his acting career with appearances in commercial
spots as a talented eight-year-old with no
professional training.
He was soon being cast in films, appearing
in St. Vincent with Bill Murray, Playing It
Cool, and Aloha before getting his first starring
role in the 2016 science fiction film Midnight
Special.
You may also recognize Lieberher from his
recurring role as Johnny Masters in the Showtime
period drama series Masters of Sex.
Jackson Robert Scott
Georgie Denbrough is Bill's cheerful and innocent
seven-year-old younger brother.
And, well, we all know what happens to Georgie.
At only eight years old, Jackson Robert Scott's
budding acting career is just beginning.
Before appearing as Georgie in It, he also
had single-episode roles in the television
shows Criminal Minds in 2015 and Fear the
Walking Dead in 2017.
Sophia Lillis
As the sole female in the Losers' Club, Bev
Marsh is an obvious target for the boys' adolescent
crushes, and every member of the club harbors
feelings for her at one point or another.
Sophia Lillis started off her acting career
with appearances in several small-budget shorts
and feature films, including A Midsummer Night's
Dream, 37, and The Garden.
In addition to It, you can spot her this year
in a role as the younger version of the lead
character in an episode of the upcoming HBO
series Sharp Objects.
Jeremy Ray Taylor
Ben Hanscom is smart and extremely talented
when it comes to inventing and engineering,
but because of his weight, he's frequently
targeted by town bully Henry Bowers and his
gang of cronies.
Before being bullied in It, Jeremy Ray Taylor
portrayed a bully himself in the 2015 superhero
movie Ant-Man.
He's also had parts in 42, Good Behavior,
and Alvin and the Chipmunks: The Road Chip.
Finn Wolfhard
Richie Tozier has a tendency to chatter incessantly,
and an overwhelming amount of bravado for
his age, alongside a considerable vocabulary
of curse words at his disposal — which duly
earns him the nickname "Trashmouth."
Of all the Losers' Club cast, Finn Wolfhard
is perhaps the most easily recognizable, due
to his leading role as Mike Wheeler in the
hit Netflix series Stranger Things.
In addition to that role, Wolfhard has also
appeared in The 100 and Supernatural, as well
as directing and starring in the music video
for the song "Sonora" from Spendtime Palace.
His next project will be as the voice of the
primary "Player" character in the upcoming
Netflix animated series Carmen Sandiego.
Jack Dylan Grazer
Where Richie is filled with bravado and appears
fearless, Eddie seems terrified of everything.
"Have you ever heard of a staph infection?"
"Oh I'll show you a staph infection."
Due to his overbearing mother, Eddie is a
chronic hypochondriac, afraid of his own shadow
and clutching his asthma inhaler like a holy
relic to ward off evil.
As the nephew of Hollywood producer Brian
Grazer, Jack Dylan Grazer's talents run in
the family.
He made his first appearance in 2014 on an
episode of The Greatest Event in Television
History, followed by roles in Comedy Bang!
Bang!, Tales of Halloween, and Scales: Mermaids
Are Real.
Following It, Grazer can be seen in the CBS
comedy series Me, Myself & I.
Chosen Jacobs
Mike serves as an unofficial "historian" for
the group — helping them connect the dots
between events in Derry's past, like the fire
at the Black Spot, the Bradley Gang shootout,
and the mass murder at the Silver Dollar.
Chosen Jacobs started his career as a musician
in Atlanta, and after moving to California,
he landed his first acting role at age 13
in a commercial for Hot Wheels.
After being cast as Will Grover in the CBS
police drama series Hawaii Five-0, he landed
his breakout role as Mike Hanlon in It with
only a single audition.
Wyatt Oleff
Stan is a bit eccentric, and his Jewish heritage
paired with his bird-calling hobby make him
a natural target for Henry Bowers and his
gang.
A pragmatic and logical boy, Stan's sound
reasoning helps the Losers' Club on more than
one occasion.
Of all the Losers' Club cast, Wyatt Oleff
has the longest list of acting credits, with
roles going back to 2012.
He's appeared in television shows like Once
Upon a Time, Shake It Up!, and Scorpion, and
you might recognize him for his role as a
young Peter Quill in both Guardians of the
Galaxy films.
Nicholas Hamilton
Henry Bowers leads a gang of high school kids
on a campaign of torment aimed at various
members of the Losers' Club — Ben Hanscom
and Mike Hanlon in particular.
It's all downhill from there.
It wasn't the only Stephen King adaptation
to feature Australian actor Nicholas Hamilton
in 2017.
He also appeared as Lucas Hanson in The Dark
Tower, and he's racked up an impressive list
of roles in his short acting career, including
parts in the Australian television series
Wanted, the feature film Strangerland, and
Captain Fantastic with Viggo Mortensen.
Owen Teague
Patrick Hockstetter is a psychopathic high
schooler who likes to lock small animals inside
an abandoned refrigerator until they die,
which makes him a perfect fit for Henry Bowers'
gang.
Owen Teague made quite a few appearances in
television shows and films before landing
the part of the psychopathic Patrick.
You may recognize him as the young version
of Walt Disney in the 2015 film Walt Before
Mickey, from other movies like Echoes of War,
or the 2016 adaptation of another Stephen
King tale, Cell. Additionally, Teague played
the role of Nolan Rayburn in over twenty episodes
of the Netflix original thriller series Bloodline.
Jake Sim
Although Reginald "Belch" Huggins isn't the
brightest crayon in the box, his size, strength,
and loyalty makes him a valuable asset to
Henry Bowers' crew.
Jake Sim's acting career really got going
in 2010 when he landed a voice role as Tommy
Tibble, in the animated series Arthur.
He also provided his voice talent to another
animated children's' show, Stella and Sam,
in 2013.
Onscreen, Sim has had roles in several other
shows, including The Amazing Gayl Pile, and
Raising Expectations.
Bill Skarsgård
At age 27, Bill Skarsgård is definitely not
one of the "kids" from It, but the terror
and suspense of the movie rests squarely on
his colorful shoulders as Pennywise.
Before taking on the role that Tim Curry made
famous in 1990, Swedish actor Bill Skarsgård
appeared in a number of films and television
shows, starting with roles in primarily Swedish
productions like Simple Simon before transitioning
to English-language feature films and shows
like Hemlock Grove, Atomic Blonde, and Allegiant.
Although he'll presumably be back for the
sequel, Skarsgård's next project is a recurring
role in the upcoming Hulu original series
Castle Rock — also based on the works of
Stephen King.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!